do you prefer more setups and shots or
less
setups and shots for a project yeah i
would
the fewer setups generally the happier i
am
um that's not to say that's always the
right way but
i do notice there's there's you know if
i'm um
if we're hosing down a scene uh meaning
okay we need to wide and then maybe we
get a second wide from here and then we
need this medium and then let's go in
for the close-up but then also
i don't enjoy that um i feel like you're
just chasing and you're basically
gathering
um pieces so that they can make it
in an edit so that in the edit so really
and this happens with a lot of projects
they're basically creating it in the
editing room
and nothing wrong with that but for me
personally
uh that doesn't interest me that much i
want to feel like we're making conscious
decisions
uh on set and
also the fewer the this is what i tell
directors a lot too is the fewer the
number of shots
the higher the quality so the more shots
you're shooting
the lower the quality each shot will be
just out of necessity
you know like you you can't make it and
so
for me trying to be uh intentional
about why you're shooting don't just
shoot a close-up because you need a
close-up in every scene
like maybe we save this then it's more
powerful when you use a close-up in the
next scene
is being intentional about how it goes
is very important to me
because otherwise i don't feel like i'm
doing anything i feel like
anybody could do it and that's fine i'm
not super interested in that
uh so yeah so for me the fewer the
setups
oh man i'd love to shoot just like a
couple shots a day i might get bored if
that were actually the case but
that implies to me that we're really
structuring
something and you're moving the camera
moves when it needs to move and it will
become and over the shoulder
you know like that these things progress
and grow
and a shot can be multiple things in one
set of
that's that's something i really love
it's hard but
uh i think it really plays beautifully
in the end if you approach it that way
you use intentional is that was that
from the four agreements
do you know that oh that is i read that
i read that when i was going through a
bad breakup some years ago yeah yeah
yeah is that be intentional with your
word i think or something is that one of
them
is it don louise miguel or forget
forgive me for the author's name but i
thought that that was part of the
the book but i could be wrong that it
was about the power of intention and the
intention of our thoughts
yeah it might be yeah yeah yeah i find
i find that that's i mean it's a big
part of
i think how i approach my work
is just what is this about and
let that drive because you could shoot
any scene any way
and so but that's not the
point like the point is this is
you know a film about loneliness or this
is a film about
family and so okay well what does that
mean family is warmth okay so that means
maybe when the family's together
that means maybe that or the dinner
table is warmer
literally the color temperature is
warmer and it feels cozy
but then when they're out in the world
it's cooler and lonely or handheld
you know it can very quickly lead
your decisions and that's how i like to
work i think that there's
there should be reason behind your
decisions
do you put a metaphysical element to a
lot of i try
yeah i try yeah for sure i've got a lot
of hippie in me
and so i love you know because
it's still ultimately you're looking for
emotional reactions to things you want
to create
emotional reactions from the audience
and so i think like
letting letting the whole thing be
ethereal if it needs to be
like i i often the way
when i'm starting a new project often
i don't know what it wants to look like
or feel like
and i'll just start going through images
images and films and music and just
gather and you know with the director or
an actor whoever else
are the creatives involved is i just
like to gather and and
going back to the soup metaphor it's
just like well okay
you don't like carrots all right so
let's not put any carrots in this soup
and it's like okay well
do you like a spicy soup oh okay so
let's start daddy
and and slowly it really
it doesn't feel like i'm making
decisions it really does
often feel like the project is slowly
revealing itself to me
when it's working really well it does
feel like there's a magic to it and that
the
the project almost already exists
somewhere like it's a little creature
somewhere
and it's just slowly you're like oh i
think this creature is furry
i think it's got a blue tint to it and
it just like
it starts to make sense
visually which is it's a weird way to
think about it but i find so pleasurable
because it feels like i'm hunting for
something and then slowly you start to
see glimpses of it and i love that
do you like things to be a challenge in
a sense
yeah i well it's interesting i
if i'm not if i'm not maybe instead of
challenged it's if i'm not engaged
in some way like i'm i'm feeling like
i'm
adding something to it and i'm i'm
working towards
something i can get bored for sure i
i i'm not i'm not attracted to
things that are just like oh you know
it's fine it's whatever you just kind of
put a light on this side and we'll shoot
it and we'll figure it out like
i i get bored i definitely get bored so
i
maybe i do need to get challenged i at
least need to be engaged
i need to find something to hook me in
there have been
there have been projects that have come
my way that i was like this is just not
a good
fit i'm not this isn't something i'm
interested enough in
i want to make sure i'm interested
because it's just so much
time this is your life you know you're
going to spend half a year
working on this thing so half a year of
your life like
it'd be nice if you care in some way one
way or another
yeah what's it like to shoot an average
seven to ten pages a day yeah so
shooting
shooting seven to ten pages a day is is
how
a lot of tv goes that's one of the
things i'll look at often
um is sometimes when i'm
being interviewed for a job or close to
being hired
sometimes by then they have uh
a page count and a number of shooting
days
and one of the first questions i will
ask is like how many uh how many pages a
day are we shooting
because it will tell me some element
about how hard this
job is going to be uh i
shot a show that we were averaging i
think we were averaging
over 10 pages a day and it sucks
it's you're just like okay
like just put up one light somewhere and
you're just going
and number of characters that's actually
secretly
that almost dictates more than because
i've noticed
uh yeah number of shooting days versus
number of pages
versus number of characters because if
there is one person
that you're shooting there are only so
many
shots of one person you need to do but
if there are eight people in a room
and it's even just a two-page scene but
everybody needs their own coverage
i shot i shot a show i shot two seasons
of a show
that has i don't know maybe
12 or 13 main characters and sometimes
they
all get together for dinner and it is a
nightmare
of 180 lines and where and it is
it's really i'm glad in hindsight i'm
glad i've done it because now
i feel like i have a good handle and
approach on those but those are
really difficult scenes and so two pages
with 12
actors is harder than 10 pages with two
actors
so that so it's an interesting added
dynamic it's like exponentially more
difficult for every additional character
that's in a room
unless you have a director uh who's
very intentional and like sure sure
there are sure there are 11 people in
here
but only this person matters and when
they
have the the fortitude to just stick
with that
and actually all we really need is a
shot that pushes in here
and maybe a wide or that's great
but usually everybody wants to cover
their butt
and so they're like well we're going to
need a close-up here and close up and
date
generally people which bums me out but
they every line of dialogue that's
spoken by anybody
they're like well we have to get that in
this shot it's like
you don't have to actually and most of
the great filmmakers
don't bother with that it's it's again
it's intention it's what's the scene
about it's not about every
person hopefully though sometimes it is
uh it's it's usually focused in on one
or two people
their dynamic and you're trying to
capture that and so you let that
lead your decisions but yeah if it's if
it's a high number of pages that you're
shooting per day
uh it's challenging
it's really hard and i i do not enjoy it
the lower the number of pages i mean
it's similar to setups
if if it's fewer pages they're going to
be shot better
they're going to be it's going to be
more cinematic or more intentional
and if it's a high page count
i hope i get another job offer then
because it's it's tough it's exhausting
and you and it really the really what
gets sacrificed first
is uh the light your light you just
can't
you can't shape the light as much
because you need to look
generally so many different directions
and so it's
a lot trickier to be intentional about
your lighting
you